so street dudes are street dudes even
now are they looking at you like
no he's he's representing what we live
correctly yeah because you were saying
that in the interview too like they
wanted to do certain things you didn't
think were authentic and you kind of
came up in it
yeah so i could yeah i just couldn't
there was one thing last season that i
just couldn't do what
ah what oh can i guess it well
uh
eat [ __ ] was it you attractive
they wanted me to be a part of like
calling the police to do something
whatever and i was just like man i just
feel like this is just the wrong move
ruth's book and it's one of them ones
where like you've
oh yeah in the show you had like a real
problem with it yeah i know so was that
originally written for you and then it
was switched no it was written for both
of us and you were like nah and i was
like nah so then they made it like i had
a real problem with it yeah yeah
but it was like one of those ones where
you know we
we fight a lot on the show to try and
like get things changed or how we want
it or how we see it authentic yeah could
be authentic and just
yeah you know i mean
not not i mean
it could be authentic yeah someone in
the streets ninja you know whatever
but i just feel like it went against
what i've built up for so ah yeah yeah
yeah you were the real one for so long
never gonna break you have your
principles and then all of a sudden
you're calling the cops yeah yeah and
like i was saying before it's like if i
knew that was going to be the case i
would have maybe tried to
plant some of those seeds
so when it happened it would be like you
know what there was a little bit of
slime about it it's almost like
duchenne's character is anything for
success he wants to win at all yes yeah
exactly you can believe it he will not
sacrifice his character will not
sacrifice his ethic and that's why it's
kind of cool to see the both of you
because duchesne understands that
that character understands that about
your character right so he's like i have
to maneuver around certain things
knowing that he's going to go wild yeah
if we break certain codes yeah like that
was probably for you that was too far
that was too far and it is the reason
why we've kind of never seen eye to eye
again and it carries on in this season
but but it's like that ain't a turn up
on a day thing and just like i'm not
doing that it's
you know you got to do you got a
emails and
thing and you know what i mean like
phone calls and so not getting
i really just don't like the direction
of this scene
it's like all all that but
we got to fight for
we've got to fight for what we believe
and we fight for these characters
because it means so much like i'm the
one that's going to have to deal with
the [ __ ] petrol station and some guys
saying like
you snitched you [ __ ] it up man you
know i mean we used to love the journey
yeah all that [ __ ] you know i mean and
it's not just for ego like i didn't want
to be extinction to think it's just i
didn't didn't think it was
it was this character like it wasn't and
i just felt like i knew him too well
um
so then yeah they ended up changing it
but it's it's it's hard work sometimes
to get anything it makes sense because
you're right but that decision changes
the entire show yeah the show is never
this it's gonna go here and now it's
going here because you fought them and
it was right but they don't know that
they're just like this [ __ ] is
changing everything i gotta change every
episode from now on because this [ __ ]
guy wants to send emails basically and
you're right but they're not going to
see that right away necessarily it's
going to take a lot yeah and then maybe
in like a year they'll be like now you
were right yeah i asked me you were
right so the thing is like what battles
to fight and you know what i mean
and like
maybe i want to fight everyone or
whatever it's like it's like having a
wife no yeah
100 you know but it's it's it's it's
difficult man and i was talking to i
remember um
speaking to idris one time and it was
like i was saying is it is it always
like this remember that that's the only
thing i've done
you know i shot a film earlier this year
but that was something but up until that
point
like it was subway so i'm i'm thinking
like is it always a fight is it always
this is it there and people say like yo
this type of shows where you you know
what you gotta say guys yeah yeah they
trust you they trust you enough they
trust the character the actors enough to
be like yo i'll let them make decisions
and and trust that we can rewrite the
show to make it work mm-hmm it's not
easy but yeah they'll let them i wonder
if it's no easy i wonder if like the
network knows how outside they are of
this culture so they're already like
listen we have almost zero connection to
what's really going on over here so if
we [ __ ] it up it's on us yeah
i'm curious like if they were writing a
sitcom about like a regular family they
could take whatever [ __ ] liberties
they want they could be hey listen
that's what the dad would say i'm sorry
i got a family exactly but some rich
hollywood [ __ ] are making a
show about the hood in england yeah they
can't exactly tell you well it's
snitching time yeah yeah yeah now for
sure and yeah
like i would recent i'll be calling like
there was was him yeah i think i was in
prison at the the beginning of yeah the
the first netflix season or whatever
yeah yeah yeah so that certain things
were happening
then i'll be calling my guys in prison
away like if this happened what would it
be oh wow you know what i mean
really instant vibe like that that would
you would have to bang it no matter if
it was free of them or like this is such
a violation it requires this and that it
then whatever and then i'll have to go
back with that because so it's like you
have to
like i yeah al because he put a lot of
black people in jail at his job
[Music]
sell out bro
remember you tackled that black guy
he was just trying to be free
you were a court officer and you got
injured tackling a guy he was what
swear to god swear to god he was like
and he tore your acl you bumped
you couldn't play in a white guy
have you ever done analysis on
like this code
this code that exists in the street have
you ever like
just sat there and thought like why
these things exist like whether you
agree with them or not and whether like
you can like
come up with understanding
for some of these decisions
you know like i understand like why you
need to be so severe in certain
circumstances because like these people
can't go to the cops
right like this is i guess this exists
with gangs of mafia exists with anything
right
but like have you ever really analyzed
code and like ask them like well why do
i have to kill these people like would
this be bad for business feel like sat
down and just said like why
yeah i mean
yeah real white question yeah i'm
curious yeah
it is but it's like interesting
i'm obsessed with the authorities
i'm obsessed with prison shows for this
reason because all the rules go away
right and then a whole new set of rules
are developed and these are the rules
that like humans really exist by yeah
right which is like
fear
authority hammurabi's code power you
[ __ ] with me i'm gonna [ __ ] you up
something's happening yeah there's no
turn to cheek yeah nothing yeah but i
think if you're probably in jail when
you've been sitting down for a long time
you
might have a different answer to those
questions than
you know the person on the outside or if
you were speaking to your
you know yourself 15 years ago yeah you
know i mean you would have still made
that decision
but i know people that are like no
matter
no matter what
no matter what was
what the violation was
that put you in jail
you know how valid that was and whatever
there will come a day in jail where you
question i didn't need to do that could
i have done it a different way there
definitely you know what i mean like
that takes sitting down on it and
analyzing it and thinking about over and
over you know what i mean yeah and kind
of like changing as a person and growing
up
you know what i mean
like
kids
just wouldn't have a lot of [ __ ] because
they don't you know
they just they just can't take
disrespect in that way
it's just like any small violation is as
a kid you don't know how fragile life is
you don't know it can go away and yeah
but sitting down for you know your your
what's my god i think is almost 15 years
into his sentence or whatever like
i bet he looks at it differently
you know
the fear of disrespect and how that will
be viewed i think that's always
prevalent right
it's like someone disrespected me
it seems almost catastrophic in reaction
this person disrespected me now nobody
will respect me i have to do something
or else everyone will stop respecting me
yeah i don't know if that's actually how
humans exist
but it seems to be the code
that you have to live by
yeah yeah
yeah oh yeah especially in those
circumstances yeah so i would make
certain decisions
for the character
that
i would not accept this
yeah and this happening to me is the
worst thing in the world yeah and it
must be dealt with
you know what i mean that might not be
how i would i would say but the
character is gonna see it yeah yeah and
and that's it and even if it means
losing money you know [ __ ] bad for
business doesn't matter getting the rest
you know i mean it's it's thing but but
the the complexity comes is like when
you see my character with his daughter
and how he wants to spend more time yeah
with her but then does things
every day that would take away that time
it's like that's the fight you know i
feel like for the last two seasons he's
been you know am i
you know what what do i want am i in
one foot in one yeah yeah yeah kind of
like yeah a little bit yeah you know i
mean but but but uncompromising yeah in
his you know i love that [ __ ] here's a
question you may or may not have
allegedly lived a life where you did
some crazy stuff well you don't know
what it wasn't this guy what no you
weren't this guy no i'm not saying
you're this guy but there's always a
path you can take where you can keep
going and get crazier and crazier or you
can be what you become which is clearly
an evolved thoughtful like artist
what veered you
this way yeah did you have a moment
where you're like if i go through with
this
my life is is very different no i never
really yeah i was never like that
deep where it was like you know
at that type of crossroad you know um
but i know many people that
were and i think had like real big
potential
and kind of went the other way i i don't
know if it's a decision to go the other
way or just you just that's why
current takes you you know i mean
um and it's too far to come back
um but that's always a shame
like when
when that happens is did that also keep
you from getting you know you said you
didn't do much did that keep you from
doing much was i'm seeing people kind of
potential and then it's nobody gets to
see it i think once you
me
are so
um
con consumed with
the art that you're creating and so
occupied you know all of your time and
whatnot
and surround yourself with
like-minded people that want to
you know do this thing for a living
there's no real room for
the average avenue um you know what i
mean once you see an opportunity
i think this passion is just a
connection to what you're creating yeah
that's just passion yeah yeah i mean
obviously much different circumstance i
grew up with suburb kids but i see grown
adults now who don't have a passion and
they just seemed so lost
that passion could change the course of
anyone yeah
not just in art or wherever yeah like
anyone's like have you pursued other
types of art obviously acting in music
but like have you experimented with like
painting or sculpting anything like that
no i when i was you know he's not gay
yeah no he's an artist bro what is this
guy talking about
have you ever worked with watercolors
before is
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
i went to college for as well for art
thank you
yeah oh and graphics don't let people
know that no i can see this this means
somebody can't be out here going to
[ __ ] art school
come on
bro he can do everything